okay so this video is gonna be on
carbohydrates and some of the chemistry
behind them so let's get started so when
it comes to carbohydrates they are one
of the four categories of organic
molecules carbohydrates you know are our
high in our our high in certain foods
such as breads pastas fruits you know
the other categories of organic
molecules
you know proteins eggs are high in
proteins and the phospholipid bilayer in
the picture
you know surrounds every cell and so
lipids is another category of organic
molecule and nucleic acids such as DNA
and organic molecules are our molecules
built around carbon now this video is
only going to discuss carbohydrates I
have others if you want to learn the
characteristics of proteins and lipids
and nucleic acids so when it comes to
carbohydrates you know some of them are
used for energy purposes for instance
glucose in the picture there is the
chemical structure of glucose glucose is
produced as a result of photosynthesis
and it's then broken down during
cellular respiration in order to make
adenosine triphosphate ATP the energy
molecule of our cells and other
carbohydrates are used to build they're
used for structure for instance the
green cell wall of plants is made from a
carbohydrate called cellulose and so
this is a structural carbohydrate
cellulose used to build the outer layer
called the cell wall of plants another
structural carbohydrate is called chitin
you know the exoskeleton of insects and
crustaceans is made from a carbohydrate
a structural carbohydrate called chitin
so carbohydrates are made from carbon
hydrogen and oxygen in a one to two to
one ratio for instance in glucose you
can see glucose has 12 hydrogen's but
only six carbons and six oxygens has
twice as many hydrogen's as carbon and
oxygen you can also see that in fruit
now notice that glucose and fructose
have the exact same formula c6h12o6 you
might be wondering how are they
different well the 24 atoms are arranged
in a different configuration molecules
like this that have the same formula but
are arranged a bit differently are
called isomers so glucose and fructose
are good examples of isomers now if you
know the 1 to 2 to 1 ratio if I were to
give you this question pretend a
carbohydrate has 4 carbons
how many hydrogens and oxygens would it
contain I hope you would know the answer
would be 8 hydrogen's and 4 oxygens
so when you study organic molecules
you're gonna hear a lot about monomers
and polymers and an analogy of a monomer
it's an a monomer first of all is a
simple organic molecule it's a building
block you know such as a brick but when
you combine a bunch of bricks you have
not what's called a monomer but a
polymer and in this case you know a
brick wall so we're gonna be showing you
how monomers are used to construct
polymers as we go through carbohydrates
and if you watch some of my other videos
on organic molecules so here are the
categories of monomers and polymers now
this video is only going to really touch
on the bottom the monomers called
monosaccharides and the polymers called
a polysaccharide so first of all
monosaccharides are the monomers of
carbohydrates they're the building
blocks glucose is a great example of a
monomer of a monosaccharide it's a
simple sugar and glucose will often bond
with other monosaccharides to form
complex sugars and before I go any
further I do want to mention that the
word saccharide is Greek for sugar so
sugars are carbohydrates so here is a
very simplistic drawing of let's say
glucose the hexagon shape and when for
instance one monosaccharide barnes with
another monosaccharide this is
holiday dye saccharide dye is a prefix
that means two so two mono
monosaccharides have been binded
together but when multiple
monosaccharides bind together this is
what is called a polysaccharide you know
these are the complex sugars examples of
this would be starch and glycogen and
cellulose which we're gonna go into more
detail in a few moments well how do
these bond together how do these
monomers bond to become polysaccharides
well there's a chemical process known as
dehydration synthesis and like the word
implies dehydration implies the removal
and the loss of water and you'll see how
that works in just a moment but
dehydration synthesis is what builds
monomers into polymers it's how all
polymers are created it's how many amino
acids form a protein it's how many
nucleotides form a nucleic acid it's how
many fatty acids and glycerol form
lipids and we're gonna discuss in a
moment its how monosaccharides bond to
form polysaccharides so here's the
chemical formula of glucose plus
fructose on the left of the arrow
glucose plus fructose so there's glucose
and there's fructose and in a
dehydration synthesis I've highlighted
in red the h2o in a dehydration
synthesis reaction these two
monosaccharides glucose on the Left
fructose on the right will bond together
and with the help of enzymes water is
removed and that bond between the two is
established so now we have sucrose c12
h22 o11
sucrose plus water this is how this is
how monosaccharides bond to form in this
case a disaccharide or we could have for
instance you know four monosaccharides
bonding to make a polysaccharide
but through dehydration synthesis is the
name of the chemical reaction so let's
look at some polysaccharides in a little
more detailed polysaccharides again
remember our long chain of
monosaccharides now the one pictured is
the polysaccharide called starch starch
is a plant polysaccharide now you know
plants do photosynthesis and they make
glucose but sometimes they make more
glucose than they use so they want to
store that glucose so the glucose is
will bond through dehydration synthesis
into starch and for simplicity you can
see that I've shown this picture right
here so here's some glucose is bonded
together and as time goes by these
starches the starch molecule can be
broken down and the energy can be
released as the plant me as the plant
has its cellular needs starches are high
in various foods such as you know rice
is high in starch and breads are high in
starch and potatoes are high in starch
now another polysaccharide I want to
mention is the animal version of starch
and that's a polysaccharide called
glycogen and glycogen is a way that
animals can store energy that hasn't
been used so when glucose is you know
consumed in our in our diet in our food
and and broken down we will then have
that leftover glucose that maybe wasn't
used and those glucoses will be bonded
into glycogen and in fact glycogen is
this enormous molecule over 30,000
glucose monomers make up a glycogen
molecule called glycogen and so these
glycogen czar often stored in our liver
and then are broken down throughout the
day as needed and then another
polysaccharide to mention is cellulose
cellulose is a structural polysaccharide
it's you know in the picture here we
have the yellow cell membrane or plasma
membrane this is the the semipermeable
of the cell that allows material in and
out and then there is the green cell
wall that is pictured here now the cell
wall of plants is made from from a
polysaccharide called cellulose and for
instance you know this explains why you
know celery is so tough and fibrous
celery is packed full of cellulose and
you know we have a real hard time
digesting foods that have a lot of
cellulose in them because we don't
possess enzymes to break down cellulose
we are we actually break down you for
instance celery because we have
microscopic bacteria that live inside of
our digestive tract that are able to do
it for us since we don't possess the
enzymes to do it ourselves
well how are polysaccharides broken down
into monosaccharides and that's through
a hydrolysis reaction hydro implies
water and lysis means to break down so
the addition of a water molecule will
help to break down a polysaccharide into
a monosaccharide and in fact hydrolysis
is how all polymers are broken down into
monomers so it's not just how
polysaccharides are broken down but it's
how for instance proteins are broken
down into amino acids it's how nucleic
acids are broken down into nucleotides
it's how lipids are broken down into
fatty acids and glycerol and it's how
polysaccharides are broken down into
monosaccharides it's the opposite of a
dehydration synthesis reaction which we
went over earlier so here is a
hydrolysis reaction of sucrose sucrose
is the large c12 h22 o11 with the
addition of water with the addition of
water and and an enzyme that's not
pictured in my animation called sucrase
but through this reaction the sucrose
has been broken down into glucose on the
left and fructose on the right this is
how in this case a disaccharide was
broken down into monosaccharides but
it's also how Polly's
a carides are broken down into
monosaccharides so before we're done i
want to refresh and just compare and
contrast dehydration synthesis to
hydrolysis dehydration synthesis is
where for instance on the monomer the
monosaccharide glucose on the left and
fructose on the right are going to bond
together to make for instance a
disaccharide this is called sucrose
again it's called a dehydration
synthesis reaction because water is
removed now underneath it we're gonna
look at hydrolysis and hydrolysis is
really just the opposite it's the
breaking down so here we have sucrose
and with the addition of water sucrose
will be broken down into glucose on the
left and fructose on the right so the
two really are just opposites of one
another and if you're in my biology
class we'll talk about this in more
detail the chapter two free response
question so there you have it you know
if you're in my class pause the video
try to answer these questions you know
write them down on a separate sheet of
paper I'm happy to check your answers
before class or after class one day so
I'll leave your comments in the box
below and thanks for watching